como era de esperarse el parlamento
francés aprobó la ley contra los
separatismos después de 15 días de
intensos debates un texto que en
realidad modifica también algunas de las
leyes más simbólicas del derecho francés
cabe destacar el artículo que tiene que
ver con la educación en la casa que
ahora va a tener un marco mucho más
estricto y que va a necesitar un aval
del ministerio de educación en caso de
que un menor pues se reciba esta
instrucción en su domicilio por otra
parte la creación de dos delitos uno el
de separatismo que lleva hasta cinco
años de cárcel 75.000 euros de multa y
también un delito para luchar contra el
odio en internet cuando se difundan
algún tipo de información de carácter
privado sobre una persona y que la vida
de esta persona pueda estar en riesgo
hasta tres años de cárcel 45.000 euros
de muerto uno de los puntos más
importantes de esta ley tiene que ver
con la regulación de las asociaciones de
culto el estado quiere mayor
transparencia en cuanto a su
financiación en cuanto a quienes las
dirigen y sobre todo si reciben algún
tipo de subsidio
público esto también abre la puerta a
que el estado pueda cerrar congregación
es algo que pues da un carácter mucho
más represivo a esta ley y hay que saber
que muchas de las congregaciones en la
francia funcionan finalmente bajo esta
figura algo que también pues han
criticado varios de los representantes
de los diferentes cultos en el país y de
hecho la comunidad musulmana pues se ha
mostrado muy descontenta diciendo que se
siente discriminada por lo que contiene
este texto este texto que ahora pasa a
ser examinado al senado a partir del
próximo 30 de marzo